every year on lindau island in Germany
dozens of Nobel laureates come to meet
with hundreds of young scientists
it's rare for so many laureates to
gather like this so I'm taking the
opportunity to ask some big questions
about the state of Medicine today to try
to get a picture of health
I just heard the story of a man here in
Germany who was HIV positive
he developed leukemia and as part of his
treatment for that he received a
bone-marrow transplant but his donor was
unlike any other the donor had a natural
immunity to HIV and the treatment cured
not only the leukemia but also the HIV
could donors like this offer hope to all
HIV patients
we know that HIV is a terrible and
tenacious disease but can we really
believe in this cure I needed to talk to
someone in the field of virology about
the implications of this surprising
development Kirsti short is a virology
researcher who attended this year's
lyndale meeting now I've been hearing
all about this patient from Berlin who
had a bone-marrow transplant and cured
his HIV tell me a little bit more it's a
pretty unique case I would say so as far
as I understand it it was a patient who
had to receive a bone-marrow transplant
because he had cancer and he was HIV
positive patient and what actually
happened is that the cells that they
transferred to displacement patient to
replace his bone marrow they were from
another person who had a certain
specific genetic mutation and the genic
mutation is in a gene called ccr5 and
that's one of the receptors for HIV so
what they did is for the Berlin patient
who had cancer and was HIV positive they
wiped out all of his immune cells but
then transferred these new immune cells
from this patient with this strange
genetic mutation into that patient what
you see is that because the ccr5
molecule is the entry receptor for HIV
so it slips at the virus infect the
immune cells if you have all the cells
in your body which lack this molecule
you're not infected with HIV so this
patient has stayed negative for HIV
since it is the gatekeeper if you like
but it's stopping the virus from
entering your cell something viruses
need to enter a cell to replicate they
can't replicate without a cell and
different viruses have different
signatures on a cell that lets them get
into the cells so yeah it's a sort of a
gatekeeper mechanism you're right I mean
it sounds like the start of a cure
what's to stop it being rolled out and
available to everybody so it's it's
difficult I think the first practical
point is a bone marrow transplant it's
not something you do every day and it's
not something you ever want to have to
go through so there's risks associated
just with the
so that's not necessarily something you
want to expose patients to it's very
expensive so we think about where the
burden of HIV is in the world this is
not going to be a feasible option in
sub-saharan Africa and brain marrow
transplants you really need to have good
matching between the new cells of the
donor and the old cells of the patient
so that's not necessarily always
possible is this only ever going to be a
treatment or is this the start of an
approach for a vaccine I think what this
case told us this receptor this entry
receptor for the virus is obviously very
important for the virus to replicate
within a human from a research
perspective targeting this this molecule
could be very important as a
preventative mechanism one of the most
eminent scientists in this field is
Francois berry Sanusi
she was in lindau attending the meeting
berry Sanusi shared the Nobel Prize for
the discovery of HIV
I think it's a pretty amazing
opportunity to really find out all the
in depth information about HIV from the
person who discovered HIV since the
weather had improved we met her by Lake
Constance Cassie and I have been talking
about this patient in Berlin who had the
bone marrow transplant I wonder if you
think that that's the start of an avenue
to explore for curing actually very
envision is what we call for us a proof
of concepts that's meaning that telling
us he could be possible we have to be
cautious and of course we he says that
with the technology that we have now we
cannot detect the virus and it is to my
knowledge the only case of cure I wonder
how you felt when you first realized
that the HIV had disappeared in that
patient first of all what we are
learning from the Berlin patient is
probably a mutation in ccr5 may be
important but the mutation is only in
Caucasian it's not an approach that can
be used widely the mutation is very rare
only 0.1% of people carrying this
mutation are resistant to infection so
we're not clear even the link between
that mutation and they it's not yet
clear whether there is a relationship
between the mutation and the fact that
the Berlin tuition is cure so if you
have to rank then sort of all their
biomedical approaches that were
currently doing in terms of creating an
HIV vaccine with this sort of approach
be high on the list as a feasible one or
no for me it's not a feasible one as
large-scale I thought but then what
would you think would be the most and
what all the research that's out there
the most
I really believe us
that we don't have yet the strategy I
strongly believe that we have to
understand a little bit better the
mechanism of latency Francois and
Kirstie explained to me that latency is
where cells are infected with HIV but
don't actually produce HIV they lie
dormant in hiding as it were and are
called reservoirs antiretroviral therapy
can produce a level of HIV in the blood
so low that is undetectable but latent
reservoirs of HIV continue to survive
and these can then reactivate the
biggest issue in the agency is that the
virus is latent in cells in the brain or
is it also that this there's latency
elsewhere like in the gut latency is
everywhere is everywhere is in the brain
is in - God is hidden does and have
known it's everywhere in the body which
make things very complicated and when
the virus is already integrated into the
cells no drug have any effect what are
we looking for cure when it seems like
the treatment although it doesn't reduce
the reservoirs it does keep the
infection under control why is it
important to look for a cure my answer
generally to that as a patient who was
the answer to know that every day you
have to take a pill for all your life
with knowing better like that after long
term you may out side effect you may
develop cancer you may develop
cardiovascular disease you may develop
metabolic disorder do you think that
public attitude to to HIV is really
becoming our and doing and so far is
that so people of my generation and
younger see HIV is as something serious
but a chronic infection you think that's
really our holding us back a little bit
yes I seem so people seems to days that
we don't care about HIV we can be
treated and of course it's to take a
pill there who is not taking one
you know that so we have this kind of
complacency yeah
it's now the moment for looking for a
cure and and yo4 for the reason we
mentioned at the beginning first of all
the Berlin patient that was a really the
first case in Neumann of cure secondly
people have been identified as what we
call elite controllers they never
receive any treatment they are infected
since more than ten years some of them
now 15 16 years there do not develop the
disease we are learning from the elite
controller but their proof of concept at
least of what we call functional cure or
what I prefer personally a remission
long lasting remission which kind of
queue are we looking for
generally when we are speaking about
cure we are speaking about eradication
that mean elimination of all latently
infected cells this is almost impossible
mission remission is probably our main
goal remission that means that we will
have a long term as without any
treatment without any risk to transmit
to other I like to say that we might be
successful I'm sure we will successful
in a remission in the future if we work
all together as we did in the very early
years of HIV research I'm gonna be your
crowning achievement lifetime's
achievement if if we can really find a
cure or vaccine oh I mean that will be a
relief for me you know even it was a
vaccine
and a cure it's really a dream but the
most things that I'm really concerned
about I would not like to leave this
world we see a reemerging HIV epidemic
that for me will be a terrible failure
and I'm I'm really worried about that
the vision of the young generation today
regarding this infection as the fact
that education information less than it
was the government less interested by
hiv/aids we have the risk and the
government and the United Nation should
take the responsibility to avoid how
does that feel as a scientist to say
that all of the amazing work discovering
all of these things is just blown out of
the water because the politicians don't
listen
oh I mean that make you not only sad you
are starting to be aggressive that was
my my thing it's how I I started to join
the voice of the activists because I
thought that was the only solution to be
together with the activists to make
pressure on the government
she was fascinating I thought I was
amazing
it was it was just it was really nice to
hear sort of her thoughts on the future
and you know it's it's so true that
infectious disease will always be so
important for human health yeah that was
very interesting as well her she was
motivated to activism yeah by the lack
of responsible politicians but
especially with HIV it's a big part of
the problem but it's it's inspiring you
know it means that what you do it does
actually in the end make a difference at
first the Berlin patient seems to offer
hope for everyone with HIV France was
and Kirsty explained it's not as simple
as that although it does show that a
cure could be possible but as treatments
progress we shouldn't take our eyes off
prevention for we risk another epidemic
you
we're here in lindau with 37 nobel
prize-winning scientists 600 young
researchers 12 of them sponsored by Mars
and people want to hear all about the
science that Mars has been doing and
well the great thing about coming to
lyndale is that we get to spend time
with sciences rock stars you aware that
you're in the presence of greatness and
the more that we can find ways of
engaging some of the finest minds in the
world to helping us solve some of these
grand challenges and then there's got to
be some great stuff in there
one of the things we do is we like to
have a lunch where we basically spend
time with the young scientists that
we've sponsored to come here and tell
them a little bit about the kind of
company that we are the kind of work
that we do and why we passionately
believe that these great scientists
should consider coming to a company like
Mars for a lifetime career in fun
science that will make the world a
better place
best part really is that you get to
actually meet these young scientists who
will look at you in the eye and say this
is the best week of my life
it is Sigma the Nobel laureate and have
a conversation that is a gift so we have
a science breakfast which is the
opportunity for us to host a discussion
around a very meaningful area of
research of healthy aging so we have Liz
Blackburn who won a Nobel Prize in this
field and we put her together with a
group of young scientists in the forum
facilitated by ourselves let's think
about the huge amount of years that
human lives are right so I made a little
scale bar for you on this high-tech
thing here this is a time scale what's
the maximum lifespan over a worm that
goes from here to here right of a fruit
fly from here to here now things get a
bit better okay let's go all the way out
to a mouse alright keep going keep going
okay we've got up to kindergarten we've
got decades and decades of life so the
science breakfasts are always great fun
highly interactive and a really good way
to have meaningful debate in an area of
public interest but also interest to
ourselves
we're in middle age here so maybe
somebody's getting some diabetes now I
mean that's the thing it's not just your
lifespan this perhaps years of living
with chronic disease I think you get the
point right I'm just constantly struck
by how we have to be thinking in terms
of enormous timescales that these things
are the world is going to be facing an
aging population we're all gonna get
older and there's gonna be a lot more of
us who are old how do we deal with that
helping young scientists realize that
they can work with somebody and realize
that these are problems that the world
has to solve and business and science
can do it together I think the private
sector can play a real role because this
sort of research that can be done by a
company that isn't necessarily related
to just the quarterly bottom line is the
kind of research that's complementary to
what governments can fund I think Mars
is a good example of that so we got 37
Nobel laureates here and just over 600
young scientists and if we can play our
role in catalyzing some of the magic
happening between those two groups of
people then we go away very happy
you